the idea of telling you something you
didn't know how many companies hold the
Press on data it's a question that
nobody knew before uh we launched the
might app um that became something that
really you know lured people in and and
got them very curious once they are in
they saw that oh my God now I can you
know really take control I can remove
things or or Services the Lo we using it
in turn really reduce my online exposure
but making it some as something that is
you know fun nicer and uh something that
they enjoy doing and not like something
that it's heavy welcome to 20-minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get
started 20 minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makea wish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
[Music]
ctec G Kobe and G welcome to 20 minut
leaders I'm so excited to have you here
thank you so much for joining me um
found
of mine how are
you great very thanks for having us
really really excited to have you um
this is a very special time not just
because you've recently announced the
phenomenal series B um in an in in quite
an interesting time in the market in the
world but also because the problem space
you're dealing with is one that is so
incredibly relevant to today's world A A
Conversation Piece you know pretty much
at every household now and one that only
going to continue growing so I'm
particularly curious about you know
going back to to your vision and to
where where you're seeing data
governance and data PR privacy going how
you seeing mine as part of that vision
and part of that the impact on the world
so G to be GNA be a lot of really
exciting things just to to kick things
off you know quickly um got Ringle maybe
take us again through you know what is
mine you know what is it that what is
this big idea that we're looking at
here so thank you for having all of us I
think it's excited I think it's the
first time that the three of us actually
sit together to do an interview uh like
that usually we're doing
that so uh it's very exciting to to sit
uh at this us and actually today we're
celebrating five years since the wow
congratulations yeah so it's uh it's a
long journey five years we're still
together uh the three of us and and I
think we it all started with uh a big uh
Vision around the gdpr so essentially
each one of us worked in you know
different places and back in um 2018 the
gdpr was uh was an Inception that went
into reality and legislated in uh Europe
for the first time the gdpr is the
Privacy
regulations um in Europe that basically
changed the internet as we know it it
gave um citizens and users as basically
that are using the internet every day a
lot of power around our personal data so
now we can ask questions we can go to
companies we can tell them hey I want to
see what data you have about me I can
take action about my data I can be more
uh in control uh to some sense and then
companies are now need to be more
responsible and accountable for the data
they collect and process so uh no more
collecting data without any per purpose
you need to really justify why you need
the data and why you want to do with it
so that was basically our kicker when we
set uh that together to think what we
want to do in our uh next company we
knew that it has to be around personal
data because the three of us really
understand personal data from many
different angles and the gdpi was like
um um enlightening that we wanted to do
a something about it and in short the
vision of the compan is to take privacy
like back then was to take privacy
regulations and to um make them
accessible to both sides of the market
so both uh to end users and companies
and uh we actually started as a purely
consumer offering uh allowing you and to
date five million users to find their
data online learn about what companies
have about them and what they can do
about it and how that make them expos in
the internet uh but then they can also
take action so we designed the journey
that you can reduce your online exposure
and essentially reach out to any company
and ask to remove your data you're no
longer using and today the vision was
revised into the other side uh like the
company side where we're basically um
allowing companies to be compliant with
different privac regulations we work
with legal teams and essentially we are
automating a lot of the daily activities
that they have to do for being compliant
um the tagline is we want to be the
single source of data proth within the
organizations so essentially today we
can come to any organization and map it
we can help them understand what system
they have what data they keep inside and
then to um take the box on all kind of
different privacy and data governance
requirement so this is a really short
way
incredible very very cool so Co Kobe
take me from from the product side and
if you're looking at you know the job to
be done and what people really want you
know if I'm going back for you know five
years back you know you're focusing on
consumer 5 million to date how you know
what is it that people need what is this
product that you're that you're building
out that is going to make a positive
impact on on
consumers yeah so um so I think that
essentially the the the main thing that
that kind of led us was obviously to
help users uh reduse their online
exposure that was like the underline you
know what we uh thought that we had when
we came into this discussion but when
you talk to
Consumers um you need to make this as
part of uh you need to touch their
emotion uh you need to make sure that
this will not only be something that is
kind of you know boring and heavy um so
the journey came you know uh let us show
you um all the assets the services the
accounts that you kind of open online
let us uh tell you something about
yourself that you didn't know
um and then the second piece was about
control Let's us allow you to take
control and take the you know um the
decision on your own terms on your own
way of how you want your data to be
avable on the internet online um and I
think that those two combine like um the
the idea of telling you something you
didn't know how many companies hold the
Press on data is a question that nobody
knew before uh we launch the M app uh
that became something that really you
know lured people in and and got them
very curious once they are in they saw
that oh my God now I can you know really
take control I can remove things or or
Services the L we using it in turn
really reduce my onine exposure but
making it some as something that is you
know fun nicer and uh something that I
enjoy doing and not like something that
is heavy um I think that the notion of
um taking control and getting visibility
of you know things that they didn't know
this is something that is car was carry
alongside to the B2B as well when G
talked about um being the single source
of data Pro um so what we we essentially
doing is creating a situation where you
have you know total understanding of
what data is being managing to patient
who has access to what telling you
things that you didn't know about you
know Shadow it uh systems that that
employees are using and the organization
in manage and so on so forth and then on
top of that providing you the controls
how can you control uh this information
whether it's because you need to do it
for compliance or whether it's because
you want to do it because of security uh
data governance and so but the
underlying you know structure or line of
thinking when dealing with data was
essentially the same give get giving you
the full visibility and then the control
on top of that
got it okay and so did you find from the
GetGo that people really cared about
this problem I mean I'm looking at the
average you know the average person
around the world and I'm looking at the
you know digitization processes over the
last decade and where we're headed what
is your experience of with people's
personal care and whether it's a concern
from from the range of concern to
excitement when it comes to data and
their and the privacy of their data uh
what have you been experiencing from the
product side over these years but on the
consumer end I have to say that well
even we were surprised by the amount of
excitement that was around uh this topic
and again I think that the way it was
communicated and built tell you
something of art with being know at the
beginning
back um you know thinking about it in
the Hing s side is kind of what you know
served us really well um so then jerking
the the your barst something that has to
be fun has to be you know not heavy want
we don't want to kind of um you know
intimidate You by telling you how much
the internet is um you know risky that
was not the key uh it was always about
showing you timeline know uh what you
have done
what you've been up to the Internet sub
and with be main factor when you know
that really brought people in uh into
the
produ that makes a lot of sense so if
we're not looking at from a
technological perspective and you know
where you know if we're actually looking
at data that's being generated and how
from the tech side companies are
evolving customer data and Journeys are
evolving in different pipes around the
world you know everything's getting in
interconnected we're expecting things to
be more seamless more automated I'm
expecting that when I go and talk to the
next auto insurance company the amount
of information hopefully the the amount
of friction or steps that I'll need to
take will be will be less because
they'll have more access or or they'll
be able to engage with more sources so
so G Golan how how have you been
observing the role of data Integrations
and data movement
over the last years and how is this
connected now to to what you're doing
with mine so data is definitely moving
around more than it used to um but both
internally in in the organization so I
think the the best example is a
marketing team that get data from all
other departments in order to generate
higher quality leads and Target the
right personas but also between
companies just as the example that you
mentioned um and then I I I think it's a
good thing because um inside a company
enhances collaboration and productivity
and between companies it can actually
benefit consumers so as you said reduce
friction for example but I think there's
um there's a line that should not be
crossed um and that line is really about
is data sharing serving the
consumer and done right with a proper
consent and and control of choice uh or
not or is you're just serving one side
of the equation um and where the second
thing happens is where we come in so
when data is shed uh without your
consent or without serving you any
benefit or value that's where mine steps
in and helps consumers reduce that data
and maybe in a way undo that sharing but
when it benefits you and gives you value
that's perfect it reduces friction it
enhances the experience it gives you the
right recommendations so we're we're all
in for that if if it's aligned with your
choice and your expectations that's
perfect um I see so I think that in in
in the simplest way how we view that
whole data integration and sharing world
and by the way just to share a few and
where and yeah just a few interesting
statistics uh on that on the consumer
side we discovered after 5 million users
that the average user has more than 350
companies that hold is personal data so
think about anytime when you travel you
purchase a flight ticket uh you book um
like an Hotel you purchase something
online it goes on and on and the data
stays there um forever you know in some
cases and on the company side it gets
even trick here we were um amazed to
know that you know after serving
hundreds of customers you know like
Reddit and hellofresh and FIFA and
Fender these are some of our cers we
learned you know the average company
doesn't have you know um a true idea of
what they are dealing with in terms of
systems so typically what we find is the
average company of a few hundreds to a
few thousand of employees typically have
around 1,6 00 assets an asset can be
anything within their Cloud environment
or any s application which is insane
they didn't know about that number and
more importantly they have no idea what
exactly what types of data they keep
within
the and uh we we are happy that we can
help them you know discover that and you
know have that holistic view of
understanding what they are dealing with
if they want to honor private
regulations and be more uh arent and add
more trust around the personal data they
collect they need to know what they are
dealing with and this is something that
we're doing very nicely with with our
customers phenomenal so um second week
of October um you're closing the series
B right $30 million um not a trivial
amount at all and not and of course not
in in the in the market conditions
you've announced it December 5th
um and so tell me a little bit about
what what does this mean for for a
company like like mine so now you're
transitioning your you Forex your
revenues in
2023 and what what what does this mean
about your your conviction in the space
about your conviction and your product
how are you as as now Founders and
entrepreneurs thinking about taking this
company to the next
level I'll start I'll take the business
side so I think that uh um R series b is
all about numbers and all about methods
it's less about the technology or L
about uh the product itself investors
want to see that you you bu you really
built a maum and you really hit product
Market uh to be um to be exact and
they want to make sure that now when
they put dollars into the company the
company can really make uh two three
four $ four dollars out of that money so
there there must be uh conviction about
a
predictability and about the ability of
the company to scale the business and I
think that uh this is what we were able
to really prove over the last two years
I must say that we were very uh
disciplined on all the you know the burn
and all the metrics and you know the
specific apis that we need to achieve uh
or as I like to say we didn't really
enjoy the 2021 party so we were very you
know very lean really did uh a lot with
uh
with less people comparing to other you
know series companies and I think that
now um the I think that what we could
really prove other than the machine and
the H of customers that we have and the
uh a is that now the Privacy Market in
2024 and 2025 is about to really take
the front stage so if we when we started
back in 2018 the BET was that privacy
with the gdpr would be copied worldwide
and you know would be uh a very hot and
important sector and I think that now we
can really see it because in the US all
the Privacy regulations are now picking
up so 12 States and this year there
should be like at least 50% more there
is the AI regulations that are also
contradict privacy and security so it it
it becomes very uh uh the the the like
the Privacy becomes a very hot Junction
between a lot of of other you know
Industries and a lot of other markets so
we are fortunate to serve all of these
markets and I think that now we have the
the money to really grow the company
across all the Departments and G and
Kobe can share a little bit about their
plans about you know the product and the
R&D and but I think that now the company
is really well positioned to uh to to to
take on the market uh we are like the I
I I put mine as in the bucket of the
Privacy 2.0 uh generation which is now
all about no code and automation which
is really two principles that we're
putting a lot of emphasis on because we
want to help companies get to AI faster
to reduce the time that they need to
spend in order to implement the product
and to have a very um plug and play as
possible so they can really touch the AI
U very
fast phenomenal Kobe gal how what is
your take on on the product on the tech
side expansions with the series
b um so I I'll think the this one I
think that um from the product
standpoint
um we we were able to introduce and
probably thanks to the to the fact that
we came from the consumer side at the
beginning but we were able to introduce
um a lot of uh you know new technologies
theability that um otherwise don't
really see them uh without a compe
um that allow us to kind of grow really
fast provide a solution that is very
fragmatic uh to companies and um and
it's basically coste effective uh when
we compare ourselves to the you know
compared to us in the space I think that
when we look at it um in for the next
two or three years now um we see a lot
of opportunity that is going Beyond uh
the real of privacy I would say uh
towards data governance as a whole and
uh to name a few examples um you know if
users or company were really concerned
about mapping their data and
understanding you know how their
technological surface kind of look like
in the organization in order to you know
support or in order to address privacy
compliance requirements nowadays they
are they're looking at the same you know
discoveries mapping that done in order
to understand okay so what do I do with
AI for example so youve seen um AI
getting you
know
through3 as something that is U growing
super fast with open Ai and and other
like um AI companies and now you have
new regulations new concerns new risks
it goes beyond privacy into other
territories but they think that what mik
can do is you know to provide the data
governance that company really need to
support any sorts of cases on top of the
data of the
very phenomenal very very cool and
gal from the tech side um we're
obviously going to expand the team
substantially and in order obviously to
meet with the business goal that goals
that g mentioned before but what it
actually means is that we we see a lot
of traction from larger and larger
companies and as those larger companies
come they obviously have more complex
use cases more complex uh Tex stxs uh
they require even more customizations
and advanced workflows so we're going to
expand the technology and the platform
substantially to cater for all of their
needs but on the same time it's really
important for us to keep the product
simple to on board and simple to use uh
having a cost effect Ive solution uh
that does not require long
implementation or development of um
efforts from the customers that's a key
differentiator we have we're going to
maintain it and even uh increase it uh
on the other hand we're going to um
expand the technology into even more and
more use cases something that we've seen
in the past year is that with the larger
companies um we have many other personas
from the customer side interacting with
our Solutions so it's not just the
privacy or legal team it's also uh the
IT team that is sometimes tusked with
some privacy requirements with their
systems or even the data platform team
that's obviously part of this equation
and now with the latest AI regulation we
are going to see researchers and data
scientists being pulled into the
conversation so we're going and they ask
us a lot of questions and they come in
with a lot of requirements that we're
going to expand the platform in order
order to cater for their needs as
well incredible so obviously it sounds
like you're you know the the the mileage
that you guys have had with with M over
the last five years have brought immense
conviction not only in the space but in
the actal product and and obviously
investors and the and and customers are
are are are backing this so it's it's a
obvious very exciting to see how things
are are changing and transforming
personally big S of your work and um
you're you're a b within our within our
ecosystem here in Israel so thank you
for the inspiration for that and uh and
the product that's so so needed during
these days and and I can only imagine
how how much more it will how much more
the need will grow in the very near
future I think that everybody's really
picking up on on what you've been
talking about for the last H for the
last five years so with that I wish you
best of luck with the journey and I'm
excited to do this again after your
series C and D and uh and uh wishing you
um you know an amazing year ahead and
sounds like an incredible clients from
the business to the tech to the product
and so thank you again for taking the
time to spend with me I'm really
honored thank you it was a pleasure and
good luck to you as
[Music]
well